if you took somebody from sea level to
the top of Everest no supplemental
oxygen no support they would be
unconscious within minutes Everest is a
very inhospitable environment hundreds
of people attempt to Summit Everest
every year during a small once a year
window that weather allows not everyone
makes it and 2023 was an especially
fatal year
[Music]
so there are a number of things that can
kill you on Mount Everest you fall into
the mountain you fall off the mountain
the mountain falls on you but because
it's the highest and because people like
to check boxes it's popular I think with
more inexperienced people that's a
problem and Dr Emily Johnston knows
she's a mountaineering guide and a
doctor trained in Wilderness emergencies
particularly at altitude she summited
Everest three times in each of the
tallest peaks in all seven continents
starting at base camp she'll break down
the physical dangers that climbers face
all the way to the top so this is ever
space camp around 17 500 feet the
molecules are twice as far apart you've
already lost half of your oxygen so 2500
meters that's when you would start to
see changes so we're well above that
here so acute Mountain sickness is Not
Unusual here people do get high altitude
pulmonary edema and hilditude cerebral
edema here as well people also get GI
problems because there are a lot of
people living here so it's not unusual
for people to get nausea vomiting
diarrhea that's probably one of the big
biggest problems at base camp is just
sanitation and a lot of people fly in
and then come up the valley and get GI
bugs so GI bugs are a big problem here
the kumbo ice fall is constantly moving
Frozen River creating deep and wide
crevasses it was also the site of a
deadly Avalanche that killed 16 in 2014.
the kubois fall is a steep area of lots
of broken ice lots of crevasses and
sorax and the biggest problem here is
that ice will fall on you or you will
fall on a crevasse it's really difficult
because there's no place to land a
helicopter because you need a flat space
you could pick somebody off with a short
haul rescue but it's unlikely that
you're going to do that no matter what
part of the mountain climbers are on
proper gear is essential not just for
staying warm but for survival here's
some of Emily's essential gear bag so
here's some of the standard gear that we
use on Everest down suit it's pretty
warm here's some big mittens and they're
so big that you actually wear another
pair of gloves underneath this is that
harness that I wear at high altitude you
have this thing we call it a crab claw
and it's connected to the harness and
you have crampons you know spikes that
you put on your feet and some gear can
save your life or kill you so this is my
ice ax pretty standard ice ax for
Glacier travel one of the ways we use
the ice ax it's not so much it's not a
walking stick it's more to stop yourself
so what you do is you turn over and you
get in Anchor position you try to get
this into the snow to slow yourself down
or stop yourself it is a tool when it's
in control it is a weapon when it's out
of control and one of the reasons
there's no wrist loop on here is if you
fall and it's attached to you with a
wrist Loop and you lose control of the
ax wow that's not a good situation Camp
3 is a 30 degree snow slope with Rocky
exposed Ledges we go up the Western comb
to Camp two which is about 21
000 feet 21 500 feet
from here we go up the Low T face to
Camp 3 which is on the low sea face one
of the big problems going from Camp two
to Camp three is that's a big jump at a
high altitude and so maybe somebody
who's had a little bit of acute Mount
sickness they've been kind of ignoring
it and they're like yeah it's just
altitude I don't feel that good Pilots
need pulmonary edema high altitude
cerebral edema are our greatest concerns
and they're not easy to diagnose high
altitude pulmonary edema particularly
it's a Continuum of brain swelling and
this brain swelling is caused by a
number of things one thing is when your
brain gets hypoxic it opens up the blood
flow to the brain and the way it kills
you is your brain is a walnut in a shell
right the shell is your skull if it
swells it can only go so far the only
way to for your brain to get out of the
shell is to go down through the bottom
of your skull which is not compatible
with Life that's high altitude cereal
edema descent is the treatment of choice
what happens sometimes though you get a
camp three it's super windy it's in a
dangerous spot you can't go down because
it's too dangerous so then you have to
treat them while they're there we have
to use a portable hyperbaric chamber
called a Gamo bag it's airtight so it's
tough if they're claustrophobic or
vomiting or whatever and then you hook
the pump up and you pump it up so that
the pressure inside the bag simulates
being at a lower altitude from a
physiologic standpoint and you have to
pump it 10 to 20 times a minute so that
they get fresh air in there and their
carbon dioxide gets expelled you can't
just leave somebody in one of these bags
because they would suffocate let's give
it a try we're going to put you in it
perfect that's great so go ahead and lie
down so I'm filling the bag with air
right now and then I'll overfill it and
that is what will simulate altitude if
you're going to rescue somebody you can
help lower them with the straps that are
attached to the outside you can use them
tactically ta-da
whoa how you doing
Camp 4 is the last stop before the
summit this is what people call the
death zone in the world there are very
few human habitations above 16 000 feet
because you're you just can't keep up
now all of a sudden you're at 26 000
feet you're 10 000 feet above that level
and so things are breaking down if you
cut yourself you don't heal very well if
you get sick you do not get better so
you're definitely in the zone where your
body can't keep up and on Summit Day
from the south call to the summit people
are driving themselves really hard
they're typically haven't been eating
and drinking very well they haven't been
sleeping well they're affected by the
hypoxia they may be hypothermic and so
this is the most dangerous place one
just environmentally the atmosphere
there's less oxygen and then two they're
tired from this whole process between
1921 and 2006 56 percent of deaths
occurred during the dissent for people
who climbed higher than 8 000 meters
getting to the summit is optional
getting back down safely is mandatory
the problem is there's also this huge
sort of catecholamine surge people are
like I did it I've achieved my goal you
think you've won the game but you
haven't you have to get all the way back
down all they're thinking about is going
home they're not thinking about putting
one foot in front of the other they
haven't been eating and drinking and
they come down and they can fall off and
it is a long way and people make big
decisions that are wrong like people
will come down a ridge and they're
supposed to go to the left and they'll
go to the right people will make poor
decisions they'll sit down and they
won't get back up because they're just
confused they just have no idea where
they are
after summoning my biggest concern is
exhaustion and dehydration you know snow
blindness can set in a little bit later
UV keratitis is the fancy name for snow
blindness it just means that your
corneas are exposed to more ultraviolet
radiation than they're accustomed to if
you are out in this ultraviolet
radiation for too long it can get to the
point where the next day it'll feel like
you have sand in your eyes and then you
won't even be able to open your eyes you
need somebody to lead you around and
there are a lot of places on the Upper
Mountain where you simply can't lead
somebody around particularly if you're
on above the South call like on a summit
bid and you get snow blindness when it
if it manifests there it'd be very
difficult to rescue somebody who can't
see Everest remains one of the safest
tall ultra high altitude Peaks to climb
simply because of all the infrastructure
despite that there was an unusual amount
of deaths on the mountain in 2023 the
reason we see so many fatalities on
Everest is it's a numbers game if you
look at the risk of dying on Everest as
compared to something like Annapurna
it's much lower on Everest it's much
lower on Everest than most of the other
8 000 meter Peaks you get more people on
the freeway and more people die in car
accidents get more people on Mount
Everest and more people will die on
Mount Everest two is whether typically
if you have a whole bunch of people
going for the summit on one day if there
are fewer Summit days in a season you're
probably going to have more problems
because you are going to have traffic
jams there are people that are box
Checkers they just want to have climb
Mount Everest and they're so driven to
be able to say that at a cocktail party
in Houston that they'll just drive
themselves to do it so a lot of people
just want to check the box
but not everybody it's incredibly
beautiful up there it's as close as you
can get to being on another planet the
sky is this impossible blue because
there's less atmosphere so the higher
you go the Bluer and deeper blue that
you get in the sky and when you get to
the edge it changes you and there is
something that happens that I can't
describe but it's very seductive
[Music]